- There are over a billion people on earth
that don't have access to clean water,
and you're complaining the
your Instagram's not growing?
Fuck you.
(gentle music)
You've just got to be thankful,
like, people just don't have perspective.
It's really easy to be energized
when you actually understand the score.
The problem is,
is that people just don't
have a perspective, right?
They don't understand that it's impossible
to be a human being.
Like, it's impossible, like
that's the rarest in the world,
and so they...
just people taking for
granted, you know, it's...
you're more likely to
win the lottery 10 times
than be alive?
400 trillion to one,
that's how rare it is to be a human being.
Everybody in this room is likely
to get hit by lightning seven times,
more likely than being
alive, that's crazy.
Perspective, and once you see
gratitude and opportunity,
life is fun.
You get to decide if you're gonna dwell,
and play prevent defense,
or if you're going to see
opportunity and be grateful,
and go on offense.
(gentle music)
I'm inspired by practicality
and reality and the truth,
which is it is ridiculously impossible
to become a human being, I am one.
I have other good things
going for me as a human being,
and I'm just grateful.
You're dwelling and looking
at what you don't have,
versus looking at what you have.
There's nothing you'll ever accomplish
that's more remarkable
than that you have a chance
to accomplish something.
When you're so grateful for
the addback, you're happy.
But people dwell about dumb shit.
What's something you think
most people take for granted?
Family time, your health,
you know, living in America,
access to clean water, food on the table,
a roof over your head.
I'm grateful for everything I have.
We lack gratitude, you
understand that, right?
I'm trying to get people to practice
reframing their perspective.
I practice gratitude every day.
If I wake up in the morning
and nobody I love passed away,
or came down with a terminal illness,
then my day starts off great.
If there was a list that
ranked everyone on earth
in terms of overall success and happiness,
from one to 7.7 billion,
where do you think you'd rank?
And this is really it for
me, this is really it.
If you actually asked me why
I'm so damn happy all the time,
I play this game all the time.
When I'm anxious, when I'm
upset about something silly,
because I'm a human, where do I rank?
When they live in London,
Dubai, or Los Angeles,
you're living amongst the
wealthiest of the wealth.
And you're looking at a very narrow window
of, like, well, my neighbor has this.
But you haven't taken it
all the way up and said,
"Look how grateful I
should be for what I have."
I love when people are
like, "Easy for you now."
No, from the get.
I cried when I got two star wars figures,
instead of one when I was six,
'cause I couldn't believe
my parents could afford
to do that.
Like, I'm grateful, I'm
grateful, gratitude, gratitude.
Like, somebody's always got it worse.
That's how I think about this.
You have to stay grateful.
You can't take things for granted.
We have so much abundance in
the world, so much opportunity,
and too many people are crying
about what they don't have,
instead of being so deeply
grateful for what they have.
(gentle music)
No, really, just stop right
now, take a deep breath.
I'm not kidding, take a deep breath.
Do it, respect it, have gratitude.
(gentle music)